la bande annonce de la suite de
bienvenue chez les ch'tis qui vient
d'être dévoilée et on l'a en avant
première mondiale une mauvaise nouvelle
je verrai n'empire mais qu'est ce qui
est pire que d'attirer vous est muté
sûreté pmp dur dur dur mais c'est dur
toute l'année comme ça où l'été ça va
parce que c'est les vacances et l'hiver
c'est les nous dans ce clip les tartes
ascenseurs et rob les perruques les
chats qui pète
tvp
[Musique]
oh
bienvenue dans le 18-20 de france inter
au sommaire
[Musique]
ça commence ça y est j'y suis
on angoisse c'est pas compliqué eric de
parler le tpm paix tu vois par exemple
tu dis pas ce programme me plaît pas tu
dis c'est dégradant ses avilissant ouais
c'est dégradant ses avis ni sens non non
non plus avec ça plus avec ça se dégrade
a cédé le dos si nice ou voilà qui est
là encore une fois c'est un ministre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rapide à huy rapide c'était pas prévu
donc je merci beaucoup et j'espère juste
maintenant que la balle à beyoncé
française va trouver son jazzy un petit
brun frisé si possible voilà qui je
pensais que j'embrasse très fort merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
c'est une vraie presse aussi souhaité
une vraie
ah ben je vous jure c'est des vrais
société bla périmés mais des vrais ceux
ci c'est au toucher ces modifications 6
pourrait toucher des saucisses pendant
des heures c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
et le gagnant bientôt car du coup de
gueule en mousse et gilles verdez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bon signe merci merci merci merci
merci parce que la concurrence était
rude
merci merci fatto combinait retransmis
dans le monde entier est prêt à faire un
petit discours où elle offre pour fat au
flou je t'aime damas l'a nommé badov ça
veut dire je t'aime on relance pour
fatwa et vous avez mis le plus
normalement con mais quand si je suis là
non une petite cotonnade et je suis dans
le métro est normalement on a raté deux
jours l'école on sait on sait là il ya
damien qui seul à penser ça me gênait qu
on sait que c'est un petit peu sous le
contrôle de maths où il a été reporté
tout va bien l'autocar du beau monde
c'est l'étude dénommée son
rajoutez un mandant merci
[Rires]
et le baise répond si tu veux je peux
rouler jusqu'à marseille
[Rires]
votre compteur c'est le meilleur plat
qui célèbre en date j'aime beaucoup mais
non moi c'est de la pâtisserie delà dans
l'ombre
[Rires]
et ben kislev sûrement push et l'autocar
du beau monde solitude est naturellement
attribué à mathieu delormeau %
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il en a deux elle fait deux saucisses de
prix et de prier et de trophées remis
par le public c'est ça qui me touche
particulièrement
apparemment vous m'aimez merci beaucoup
et si ça peut donner des idées à à cyril
pour une émission sur d8 par exemple ça
peut être pas mal donc voila merci
beaucoup à tous et puis ça peut toujours
de prix que morandini n'aura pas donc
voilà mais je me sens oui c'est ça dont
l'europe la plage non mais je suis là
vous l'avez trouvée chez care voulait
plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais là
vous êtes né au patinage artistique pour
voir ça va très bien et qu'il y fait ça
mais je sais pas qui font un pas il faut
qu'il arrête de ma mère on dirait qu un
morpion la b2